Це, мабуть, чи не найбільший
спеціалізований музей гончарства не лише в Україні,
а й, мабуть, у Східній Європі.
Оскільки наша колекція налічує
більше 60 тисяч експонатів.
Родзинкою цієї колекції
є збірка великих монументальних робіт.
Вони дуже часто шокують наших гостей.
Починаючи із 1997-го року,
ми в музеї, для художників-керамістів,
проводимо таку творчу акцію, як симпозіуми.
Майстри в нас приїжджають сюди, на територію музею.
Ми їм даємо певний час, зрозуміло,
для створення конкурсних робіт.
Даємо матеріал — глину і даємо тему для роботи.
Так от, за роки проведення цих симпозіумів
наша колекція збагатилася
більше ніж на 300 великих монументальних робіт,
які утворили колекцію садово-паркової
монументальної керамічної скульптури.
Починаючи з 2010-го року це змагання
у нас набуло статусу міжнародного.
Одна із найбільш цікавих, стилістично вирішених
робіт, до вашої уваги, «Доброго ранку, Опішне».
І ця робота знайомить нас із звичайною
гончарською родиною на чолі з самим патріархом.
Є берегиня роду, яка на руках тримає мале дитя.
І є продовжувач родинних традицій.
Він поки що розважається, відпочиває.
Мабуть, зовсім скоро почне допомагати батькові
в складному гончарському ремеслі.
До речі, за етнографічними даними в Україні
до гончарства долучали, приблизно, з семирічного віку.
Це такі ази, які згодом уже можна було дорослому
гончареві використати для свого професійного росту.
Ця робота унікальна.
Унікальна, можна сказати, з усіх боків.
Створена вона 1997-го року на нашому першому симпозіумі.
Вона теж всередині пустотіла,
але унікальна вона тим, що вона — монолітна.
З моменту створення,
її нікуди не переносили і не перевозили.
Якщо її уявити в сирому вигляді, то зрозуміло,
що чотири пустотілі ніжки просто
не витримали ваги двух голів і тулуба.
І автор це теж розумів.
І щоб надати роботі стійкості,
він спочатку виготовив дерев’яний каркас.
Потім — металевий, і вже потім зверху
металевий обклав глиняними пластинами й декорував.
Коли робота висохла,
виникла наступна проблема — випалювання.
Щоб випалити цього лева майстер над ним створив
окреме горно, як саркофаг, окрему будівлю.
Після випалювання він його розібрав.
І саме під час випалу стало зрозуміло,
чому було два каркаси.
Перший, дерев’яний, згорів.
І своє тепло віддав для того,
щоб випалити роботу зсередини.
А металева конструкція до цього часу тримає роботу.
Робота за своїми контурами нагадує дерево.
Дерево — це символ життя у наших предків.
На стовбурі ось такі свастики, символічні птахи.
За уявленнями наших предків вони
переносили душі померлих людей на небо.
Центральний образ роботи —
іконописне зображення Божої Матері.
Воно виконане з дотриманням всіх церковних канонів.
Руки — навхрест.
Права рука зверху, долоні повернуті
до тіла і голова схилена в покорі.
Одна долоня виходить на один бік,
а інша на другий, вона ніби обіймає.
Ось таке положення рук говорить нам про те,
що де б ми з вами не знаходились,
відносно цієї роботи, ми завжди
будемо під охороною Божої Матері.
Цей краєвид, вам буде підтвердженням того,
що наша Опішня — це не рівнинне поселення.
Це одне з найвищих географічних поселень Полтавщини.
А пагорб, що перед вами, —
одна з найвищих її географічних точок.
Це наша гончарна майстерня.
Тут наші відвідувачі беруть експрес-уроки, так би мовити.
Експрес майстер-класи для них проводять наші майстри
із роботи за гончарним кругом і гончарської мальовки.
Галерея мисок.
Миски представлено по регіонах для того,
щоб можна було краще уявити,
які стильові можливості в кольоровій гамі,
в декорі, в малюнку, щоб можна було відрізнити.
Якщо порівнювати миски, які на цій стіні,
то відразу впадає в око жовто-зелена,
коричнева, кольорова гама Карпатських гір.
Отут представлено посуд із Західної України:
Косів, Пистань, Івано-Франківщина.
Це — миски, привезені із Буковини.
Виготовлені вони майже 100 років тому,
в 20-і роки минулого століття.
І це миски, які декоровані технікою затікання.
Брали кольори різного відтінка ангоба.
Ангоб — це глина, по глині якої виконується розпис.
Так от і заповнювали внутрішню поверхню миски.
Потім її повертали, ангоби
ось таким чином розтікалися,
і було гарно видно місце, де ангоби виливали.
Після того, як їх виливали,
вони між собою перемішувалися.
Відповідно, потім для повторного
використання були непридатні.
Відповідно, цей спосіб декору був дуже дорогий
і такі миски зазвичай робили тільки під замовлення.
На цій стіні представлений посуд з Вінничини,
Чернігівщини, Черкащини і Хмельниччини.
Якщо порівнювати з Івано-Франківщиною:
темніша кольорова гама,
тут, переважно, ось такі червоно-вохристі кольори.
Це галерея слави опішнянського гончарства.
На цих роботах полтавського художника
Валерія Мозика ви бачите тих людей,
які творили і продовжують творити
славу Опішні як гончарної столиці України.
Тут на всіх, без винятку, роботах,
художник зобразив ще руки майстрів.
Натрудженні, мозолисті, працьовиті, можливо,
в деяких моментах вони навіть непропорційно великі.
Але це говорить нам про те, що праця гончара —
доволі важка фізична робота.
І де в кого руки, бачите, зайняті роботою,
ну де в кого, здається, відпочивають.
Але коли дивишся, то складається враження,
що вони будь-якої миті
готові взяти грудку глини
і почати процес творіння.